are you ready for another elephant
Gambit surprise
after E4 E5 Knight to F3 and D5
White's second most popular choice is to
take on E5 and here rather than taking
on e4 black plays this crafty move Queen
to E7 attacking Knight as well as on the
e-born so white has to play D4
and exactly here with sets up the trap
with F6
okay it's time to look at the database
more than 54 000 people goes with Queen
to S5 checks thinking that after G6 and
Knight captures G6
they are at least winning the material
but to the surprise after Black's next
amazing reply Queen captures E4 actually
it is black who has come out as a
complete peace Advantage at just 7th
rule of the game